elle avait renoncé à le faire au tout
début de l' enquête puis elle a fini par
craquer depuis quelques jours la photo
et le nom de celui qu'elle considère
comme responsable du décès de sa fille
tourne en boucle sur les réseaux sociaux
même si police et justice sont sur le
coup je sais qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils
font leur maximum qu'ils ont fait leur
maximum continue je sais que c'est pas
du tout laisse à l'abandon c'est juste
que moi en tant que maman ben jeu comme
à nous en cage j'ai l'impression d'être
impuissante et j'essaye de de chercher
des solutions
des solutions pour aider la police des
solutions pour savoir comment sarah 27
ans a perdu la vie le 18 juin dernier
dans un appartement de montbéliard elle
y avait rejoint un homme qu'elle
fréquentait depuis quelque temps un
citoyen algérien de 41 ans au casier
très épais entre autres pour des faits
de violences sur deux ex compagne un
suspect que la justice recherche
activement est ce que ça peut nuire à
lenquête je ne pense pas est ce que cela
peut perturber l'enquète je ne pense pas
non plus que ça peut la vert à faire
avancer je poursuis pas certaines n'ont
plus la présomption d'innocence impose
quand même de rappeler que cette
personne est peut-être suspecte mais
qu'elle peut aussi être innocent pour on
ne sait jamais et que l'usagé des
réseaux sociaux à ce titre n'a peut être
un peu délicat en rejoignant la trop
longue liste des féminicides le décès de
sarah avait profondément ému bien
au-delà du cercle de ses proches l'appel
à témoin ouvre donc une dangereuse boîte
de pandore s'il s'avérait que c'était
pas lui oui s'ils s'avéraient mais bon
vin dans ce cas là c'était pas lui
présenter mes plus plates excuses mais
bon il ya beaucoup de chances que ce
soit lui quand même et si quelqu'un se
mettait en tête de faire justice lui
même j'ai pas pensé honnêtement je n'ai
pas pensé à ça du tout ça m'a même pas
effleuré l'esprit
moi ma tête elle est tournée vers ma
fille qui est parti brutalement
violemment
lui ce qui peut lui arriver c'est pas
mon affaire au fait agir plutôt
qu'attendre l'urgence de la douleur
n'est pas toujours compatible avec le
temps de la justice c'est pourtant bien
ce temps qu'elle met à profit c'est
aussi ce temps qui joue pour nous pour
l'institution judiciaire et pour la
justice pour la vérité parce que tenir
une cavale dans la durée c'est difficile
donc plus le temps on va passer plus ce
sera difficile plus discret que facebook
le réseau interpol est aussi à l'oeuvre
tôt ou tard loeb devra rendre des
comptes